as you can see the receiver itself is
pretty simple extend the broadcast
receiver class and override the on
receive handler as you can see here
receivers are lightweight components
meant to listen for broadcasts react and
complete within 5 seconds that usually
means simply starting a service or
sending notification to have your
receiver start listening for broadcasts
you need to register it either through
an entry in your manifest like this or
dynamically within another application
component usually an activity like this
then you define the intent filter that
specifies the broadcast event you want
to receive you can do that either here
in the manifest or if you're registering
your receiver with an application
component such as an activity you can
create your new intent filter like this
the biggest difference between manifests
and dynamic receivers is when they're
triggered a programmatically registered
receiver will only receive broadcasts
while the app is running while a
manifest declared receiver will start
your app specifically to receive your
broadcasts for example I usually code
with my noise-canceling headphones on so
a music app like this might want to
register a runtime receiver to listen
for the system intent broadcast that
announces when headphones are unplugged
that will allow it to automatically
pause playback when the audio routing
switches from headphones to speakers in
this case we can use a runtime receiver
because the app is guaranteed to be
running if music is playing on the other
hand if I'm using Google Cloud messaging
to listen for new data for my server I
want to register a manifest receiver
that always listens for incoming tickles
from my server and will wake up my app
if it's being terminated to trigger the
update code usually a sync adapter which
is something we'll discuss later in
lesson 6 there's a bunch of system
broadcasts you can monitor to help your
app react to changes in system you can
see the system broadcast actions within
the intent documentation at
developer.android.com one great use for
broadcast receivers is to monitor for
changes to internet connectivity or
charging status imagine your app has to
upload a movie or calculate the next ten
thousand moves in game of chess how
might you use a receiver to wait until
the device is plugged in before starting
that process should it be a manifest
receiver or a broadcast